George Bush made a mistake we can make
mistakes but that one was a beauty we
should have never been in Iraq we have
destabilized the Middle East they lie
okay said there were weapons of mass
destruction there was none and they knew
there were none I'm sick and tired of
Barack Obama blaming my brother for all
of the problems that he's had and
frankly I could I could care less about
the insults that Donald Trump gives to
me it's blood sport for him fares man
kicked and tired of him going after my
family World Trade Center came dad all
rather well my love for that I just want
to say at least on behalf of me and my
family I thank God all the time that it
was george w bush in the White House on
911 and not outdoor the World Trade
Center came down because Bill Clinton
didn't kill Osama bin Laden when he had
the chance to kill him in fact that
country was drawn the borders of that
country were drawn after World War 1 by
Westerners that didn't understand what
was happening there the tragedy of it is
that we're still embroiled